You know, if you think about it, the idea of April Fools' Day is just absurd, a day set aside in which we're allowed, basically, to admit that it's fun to deceive each other. This notion, this idea, is so profoundly disturbing that we have to quarantine it into its own day on April 1. But April Fools' Day is for amateurs. The biggest liars, the most disturbing liars are the people who lose their grip on what the truth is and cannot even tell they're lying.
你瞧，仔细想想，愚人节这个点子其实荒唐透顶。这一天被专门设立出来，本质上是允许我们承认欺骗他人是一件很有趣的事。这种观念，这种想法，深刻得令人不安，以至于我们不得不把它“隔离”到4月1日这一天。但愚人节只是给业余选手准备的。最大的骗子、最令人不安的骗子，是那些已经失去了对真理的掌控，甚至连自己是否在撒谎都分不清的人。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, with April Fools' Day approaching, an hour of stories about deceptions perpetrated by compulsive liars. Portions of these stories have aired on NPR'S Morning Edition years ago. They get replayed here on Chicago's public radio station every April 1. Our contributing editor Margy Rochlin and I produced them. Margy narrates.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天节目里，随着愚人节的临近，我们将讲述一个关于强迫性说谎者实施欺骗的故事集锦。这些故事的部分内容几年前曾在国家公共电台（NPR）的《早间新闻》节目中播出。它们每年4月1日都会在芝加哥的公共广播电台重播。这些故事由我们的特约编辑玛吉·罗克林（Margy Rochlin）和我共同制作，玛吉担任旁白。
I've been talking to a lot of people about liars lately. Here are two things I've noticed. One is that everyone has a story about some nut in their past, not just a liar but a compulsive liar, somebody who told so many incredible stories about themselves that eventually people came to wonder if the liar even knew what was real. The other thing I noticed is how vividly people remember these stories. Maybe it's because something so basic was violated by the lies, some basic trust. They remember the details because they're still trying to sort it out.
最近我一直在和很多人谈论“骗子”这个话题。我发现了两件事。第一，每个人都有过一段关于过去某个“疯子”的故事，不仅仅是个骗子，还是个强迫性说谎者。他们编造了那么多关于自己的离奇故事，以至于最终人们开始怀疑，这个骗子自己是否还知道什么是真实的。我注意到的另一件事是，人们对这些故事的记忆是多么深刻。也许是因为谎言触犯了某种根本的东西——某种基本的信任。他们记得细节，因为他们仍在试图理清这一切。
He had the most unbelievable eyes.
他的眼神不可思议。
He didn't have an affect that hinted at the desire for me to believe it.
他的神情中丝毫没有流露出希望我相信他的欲望。
They were like this blue-gray, but they changed color.
他的眼睛是蓝灰色的，但颜色会变。
He had an affect that said, I believe this.
他的神情仿佛在说：我相信这是真的。
You could never tell he was lying by his eyes. He was so sincere.
你永远无法从他的眼神中看出他在撒谎，他显得太真诚了。
She had shark-like eyes.
她有双像鲨鱼一样的眼睛。
He is a very charming person, and I think a lot of compulsive liars are charming people.
他是个非常有魅力的人，而且我认为很多强迫性说谎者都是很有魅力的人。
Sharp teeth.
锋利的牙齿。
I mean, I think that he believed everything he told you. He passionately, firmly believed.
我是说，我觉得他相信他告诉你的每一件事。他充满激情、坚定不移地相信着。
When she laughed, her eyes didn't laugh. Her whole face laughed, and she made the sounds of laughing. But she herself didn't laugh.
当她笑的时候，她的眼睛并没有笑。她整个脸在笑，还发出了笑声。但她自己并没有在笑。
Sometimes you know you're being lied to, but at first, you don't take it that seriously. You rationalize to yourself that everyone has their eccentricities. Maybe this is a temporary condition. Maybe they're just troubled. Maybe you can help them.
有时你知道自己在被骗，但起初你不会太当回事。你会向自己合理化解释，认为每个人都有怪癖。也许这只是暂时的状况。也许他们只是遇到了困难。也许你可以帮助他们。
People kept saying to me, this guy's this. This guy's that. This guy's this. Can't you see that? And I was so busy protecting him that I said, OK, I'll show you what a good guy this is. I'll marry him. We went out, and we were together for a couple of years before we got married. And he would tell me these things, and things just kept not adding up. One of the instances that I can think of is that one day, my ex-husband came over. And he was crying, and he said that he was really upset. And he told me that his mother had died. And I gave him tea and sympathy for weeks. We didn't even really leave the house.
人们一直对我说：这家伙是这种人，那家伙是那种人。难道你看不出来吗？我当时忙着保护他，我说：好吧，我要向你们证明他是个好人。我要嫁给他。我们约会了，在结婚前在一起待了几年。他会告诉我一些事情，但事情总是对不上号。我能想到的其中一个例子是，有一天我前夫过来了。他哭了，说他非常难过。他告诉我他母亲去世了。我有几周时间一直在给他送茶、安慰他。我们甚至都没怎么出过家门。
Then he moved in with me, and we started getting letters from where I knew his mother lived with his mother's initials on it. And he said, well, my mother had nine brothers and sisters, and this is coming from my aunt. And my aunt has exactly the same initials that my mother had. And one day, I just opened one of those letters. And I read it. It was like, "Dear son." And it didn't say, "Dear son, I'm writing to you from my grave." "Dear son, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. Love, Mom." Hmm, this is interesting. What about these letters? "Well, these letters were written to me before she died." "Oh! She postmarked them from purgatory, wherever she is."
后来他搬来跟我住，我们开始收到一些寄件地址是我知道他母亲住处的信，上面还有他母亲名字的首字母缩写。他说：噢，我母亲有九个兄弟姐妹，这是我姨妈寄来的。我姨妈的名字缩写和我母亲的一模一样。有一天，我拆开了其中一封信。我读了信。信开头写着：“亲爱的儿子。”而且信里并没有写：“亲爱的儿子，我正从坟墓里给你写信。”信里写的是：“亲爱的儿子，巴拉巴拉……爱你的妈妈。”嗯，这很有趣。这些信是怎么回事？“噢，这些信是她在去世前写给我的。”“噢！她是把信从炼狱或者无论她在哪儿的地方寄出来的吗？”
Oh, boy. He would get these boxes from somebody back east. And he said, this is somebody who was very close to me. But then getting nosier, nosier, nosier, I found a letter from her, because you can't hide everything. And here was this woman who said that in fact she was his wife. And how was he doing, and she was worried about him, and when was he going to come see her. And then he disappeared.
天哪。他会收到一些从东部寄来的盒子。他说，这是一个和他关系非常亲密的人寄来的。但后来因为我越来越好奇，我发现了她写来的一封信，因为你不可能藏住一切。信里这个女人说，其实她是他的妻子。她问他最近怎么样，她很担心他，问他什么时候能去看她。然后他就失踪了。
Then he showed up again. And he said that he had been involved with the mob and that he had to get out of it, and he really wanted to clean up his act. And I knew that he wasn't smart enough to be involved with them. But in fact, where did he go? And I wouldn't hear from him, and I wouldn't hear from him. I was becoming more and more worried and more and more concerned. And I felt like he had somehow been victimized and that was what was making him tell these lies.
后来他又出现了。他说他卷入了黑帮，不得不脱身，他真的很想改过自新。我知道他没那个脑子卷入黑帮。但实际上，他去哪儿了呢？我一直没听到他的消息。我变得越来越担心、越来越焦躁。我觉得他可能以某种方式成了受害者，而这正是导致他撒谎的原因。
And he showed up with nothing. A few weeks later, he got a box from the woman in Maine. And there were some of the clothes that he had left with. Hmm, this is interesting. You tell me you're in Chicago trying to get out of being with the mob, and they have you locked in a room. Well, he said that this woman was like a mafia princess. [LAUGHS] Which I really thought was perfect. Married to the mob. Real life. And that she would go to Maine to buy clothes, and her father was wealthy. I don't know. The story was so cockamamie. And I thought, if you're a mafia princess, why would you want to buy your clothes at L.L. Bean?
他回来时一无所有。几周后，他收到了那个缅因州女人寄来的一个盒子。里面装的是他离开时带着的一些衣服。嗯，这很有趣。你告诉我你在芝加哥试图脱离黑帮，他们把你锁在屋里。好吧，他说那个女人像个黑帮公主。[笑]我觉得这太绝了。嫁给黑帮。真实生活。而且她还会去缅因州买衣服，她父亲很有钱。我不知道。这个故事太荒谬了。我心想，如果你是个黑帮公主，为什么非要在大众户外品牌L.L. Bean买衣服？
The one thing that I did not feel that he lied about is that he worshipped the ground that I walked on. And he would say, I think you're the most beautiful woman I've ever seen. And whether that was a lie or not, that was the kinds of lies you want to hear.
有一件事我觉得他没撒谎，那就是他崇拜我所走过的每一寸土地。他会说，我觉得你是我见过的最美的女人。无论那是不是谎言，那都是你想听到的那种谎言。
When I figured out that he had had who knows how many other lives, complete lives, one of the things that I realized is that he would create a person, and if that person didn't work, that he would just leave that person, leave that body, leave that location that he was living in, move to a new place, start with a new person, and build a whole new life and say, hmm, maybe this person will work, maybe people will like this person, maybe I'll like this person.
当我意识到他可能还有过数不清的其他生活，完整的、多重的生活时，我意识到的一点是：他会创造一个角色，如果这个角色行不通，他就会抛弃那个人，离开那个躯壳，离开他居住的地方，搬到一个新地方，以一个新的身份开始，建立一个全新的生活，然后说：嗯，也许这个身份会管用，也许人们会喜欢这个人，也许我会喜欢这个人。
Sometimes you want so much to believe somebody, even if you know that they're a liar, that you try to keep from putting them in a position where they're going to lie. So you don't ask them anything. Then the only reason to ask a question is because it becomes like a comedy routine. It's like, what kind of story will I hear if I throw this question out? And sometimes when I would be in a sick mood, I would do that kind of stuff, just to hear, hmm, I need a little story.
有时你太想相信某个人了，即使你知道他们是个骗子，你也会尽量避免让他们处于必须撒谎的境地。所以你什么都不问他们。这样一来，问问题的唯一理由就变成了像在演喜剧。就像在想：如果我抛出这个问题，我会听到什么样的故事？有时当我心情不好的时候，我就会那样做，仅仅是为了听听：嗯，我需要一段小故事。
When our second baby was born, he couldn't handle it, and he got into drugs. And I would say to him, the only way we can work on it is for you to admit to me and not lie to me and tell me, I have a problem. And he would say, I don't. And I'd say, you do, and you're lying, and tell me the truth or leave.
当我们第二个孩子出生时，他应付不来，开始沾染毒品。我会对他说：我们解决问题的唯一方法就是你向我承认，不许对我撒谎，告诉我，我有问题。他会说，我没有。我会说，你有，你在撒谎，要么告诉我真相，要么滚蛋。
I think that what I noticed the most from the hour that he left was that I just kept sighing. I would just go [SIGHS] I couldn't talk to anybody without sighing. I was just so relieved.
我觉得他离开的那一刻，我最明显的反应就是我不停地叹气。我不停地……（叹气声），我跟任何人说话都必须叹着气说。我当时感到如释重负。
People would say to me, well, you know, he's wrapped up in drugs, and he's not thinking straight. Do you think that he might come and hurt you? And I thought, maybe he's taking on yet another life. And he's gone through too many lives, and he is going to, in fact, come and kill me and kill the kids and disappear. And that was the only time I thought, suddenly all these lies, it's scary. I felt a lot of fear, and I didn't sleep. I didn't sleep, and I had bars put on all my windows and all my doors. It wasn't funny. It wasn't something I could deal with. And it wasn't something I ever wanted to deal with again.
人们会对我说：你知道，他陷进毒品里了，脑子不清醒。你觉得他会不会回来伤害你？我想，也许他又要开启另一段人生了。他经历过太多的生活，他可能会回来杀了我，杀了孩子们，然后消失。那是我唯一一次心生恐惧，突然觉得这些谎言很可怕。我感到非常恐惧，睡不着觉。我睡不着，我在所有的窗户和门上都装了防盗栅栏。这可一点都不好笑。这不是我能应付的事。这也不是我以后还想再面对的事。
One of the things that is very important in all of this, and why I sound calm, is that I really didn't love him. I wasn't in love with him. So that was my own lie. So I was lying too. I was saying, yes, I love you. Yes, I know it doesn't seem like it, but, yes, I love you. It would come out of mouth because you don't want to say to somebody, no, I don't love you, but I want to stay married. And so it was my own lie too.
在这一切中有一点非常重要，也是为什么我现在听起来很平静的原因——那就是我真的不爱他。我当时并不爱他。所以那是我自己的谎言。所以我也在撒谎。我在说：是的，我爱你。是的，我知道看起来不像，但，是的，我爱你。这话会不由自主地说出来，因为你不想对人说：不，我不爱你，但我还想维持婚姻。所以，那也是我自己的谎言。
In that self-deception, in thinking that I could make this work, that was the biggest lie of all. And it isn't other people's lies that they're going to tell me in my life. What I just have to constantly keep working on is not lying to myself, not deceiving myself. And it's difficult. It's really hard.
那种自欺欺人，认为我能维持这段关系的想法，才是最大的谎言。我这一生中，问题不在于别人会对我撒什么谎。我真正需要不断努力做到的是：不欺骗自己，不自欺。这很难。真的很难。
Psychiatry, we're told, is a science. And given the fact that lying is so common, you'd imagine that someone had thoroughly disassembled this personality disorder, figured out why some people's reasonable truth mechanism gets jammed between gears. So we called up these two experts to find out what they knew, psychologist Paul Ekman, a researcher at the University of California at San Francisco, and Brian King, a psychiatrist at the UCLA School of Medicine. Dr. King has surveyed the published psychiatric material online, and here's what he says.
我们常听说精神病学是一门科学。鉴于撒谎如此普遍，你会以为有人已经彻底剖析过这种人格障碍，弄清楚了为什么有些人的理性真理机制会在齿轮间卡住。于是我们联系了两位专家来了解他们的见解：加州大学旧金山分校的研究员、心理学家保罗·埃克曼（Paul Ekman），以及加州大学洛杉矶分校医学院的精神科医生布莱恩·金（Brian King）。金医生浏览了网上已发表的精神病学资料，以下是他的说法。
It's quite remarkable. There's been relatively little attention devoted to it. If you look at the world literature over the past 100 years, you come up with maybe 70, 80 cases.
这非常了不起。对此的研究确实相对较少。如果你查阅过去100年的世界文献，大概只能找到70到80个相关案例。
There's been very little research on compulsive liars because they don't come into your office. They don't seek help, and they're not interested in cooperating in research. And there's nothing in it for them.
关于强迫性说谎者的研究很少，因为他们不会走进你的办公室。他们不会寻求帮助，也不愿配合研究。这对他们来说没什么好处。
And as for the scientific research that has been done, the results are pretty disturbing. For instance, studies have shown that most people cannot tell when they're being lied to. That's true even of people who are specially trained to detect liars. Then there are the case studies.
至于已经开展的科学研究，结果相当令人不安。例如，研究表明大多数人无法分辨自己何时在被骗。即使是受过专门训练的测谎人员也是如此。然后就是这些案例研究。
It's hard to offer a great deal of hope to anyone who's intimately involved with a compulsive liar, because there's very little reason to believe that they're going to change.
对于那些与强迫性说谎者有亲密关系的人来说，很难提供太多的希望，因为几乎没有任何理由相信他们会改变。
Some people have written that lying is something that is very difficult to treat, that in order to have a treatment response, you have to have someone who is able to live with the truth that therapy is based on the ability to tolerate and explore the truth.
有些人写道，撒谎是一种非常难以治疗的行为，为了获得治疗效果，你必须拥有一个能够接受真理的人，因为治疗本身就是基于忍受和探索真相的能力。
I would categorize myself as a liar. Even in the safe confines of a therapist's office, you're still tempted to lie. In fact, you guys here have no idea whether or not I'm making this up or not.
我会把自己归类为骗子。即使是在治疗师办公室这种安全的环境里，你仍然会被诱惑去撒谎。事实上，你们这些听众根本不知道我是在编故事，还是在说实话。
No one can be exactly certain as to why some people become compulsive liars, but the two motives that are most likely are the power motive, the compulsive liar who lies because they want to control you. You see this in early adolescence, where kids will lie solely for the reason of demonstrating that they can beat the old man, that they can put one over on their parents. Well, some people never grow out of that.
没有人能完全确定为什么有些人会成为强迫性说谎者，但最可能的两种动机之一是“权力动机”。强迫性说谎者撒谎是因为他们想要控制你。这在青春期早期很常见，孩子们撒谎仅仅是为了证明他们能打败长辈，能骗过父母。好吧，有些人永远长不大。
It becomes a game. In one particular store, they refused to give me a cash exchange for a particular piece of merchandise. I told them I was joining the Marines in the next couple weeks and being shipped off to Saudi Arabia. That was an instance where I thought, well, this would be kind of funny.
这变成了一种游戏。在某家店里，他们拒绝让我凭收据退换某件商品。我告诉他们我接下来几周就要加入海军陆战队并被派往沙特阿拉伯了。当时我心想，这应该会挺有意思的。
Maybe there is a little bit of a charge that comes with the successful telling of a lie, the rush of duping someone else, particularly someone who is perceived to be more powerful than you are.
也许成功撒谎后会带来一点快感，那种愚弄他人的冲动，尤其是当你愚弄的对象被认为比你更有权势时。
Probably more common than that is the compulsive liar who's like the name-dropper, but the name-dropper taken to the nth degree.
可能比这更常见的是那种像“爱炫耀人脉”的人，但这种人的爱炫耀程度达到了极致。
One day I heard him telling somebody his father was the CEO to Ford Motor Company.
有一天我听到他告诉别人，他父亲是福特汽车公司的CEO。
They are trying to impress you.
他们试图给你留下深刻印象。
Sharky started telling me all these things, how she had this uncle, and the uncle was the president of 20th Century Fox and that she had worked there as a film editor.
那个鲨鱼眼女孩开始告诉我各种事情，说她有个叔叔是二十世纪福克斯公司的总裁，而她曾在那里做过电影剪辑师。
They get our attention. They get our interest. They get our admiration. And in a sense, you might think of them as being addicted to that type of admiration.
他们成功引起了我们的注意，引起了我们的兴趣，赢得了我们的钦佩。从某种意义上说，你可以认为他们对那种钦佩感上瘾了。
For some reason, I seem to really seek approval from people, especially women. And generally, people will believe what they hear. And once I get that approval, whether it be, yeah, let's go to bed, let's have a relationship, let's have a drink, or just a smile, that was enough. That was my fix.
出于某种原因，我似乎真的很渴望得到人们的认可，尤其是女性的认可。通常人们会听什么就信什么。一旦我获得了那种认可——无论是“好吧，我们可以上床，可以谈恋爱，可以喝一杯”，还是仅仅一个微笑——这就足够了。那就是我的“毒瘾”。
Again, like an addiction to anything, be it alcohol, be it gambling, whatever, the drive is that the next time I engage in this behavior is going to be the one that's fulfilling.
和任何成瘾一样，无论是酗酒还是赌博，驱动力都是：下一次我这么做的时候，一定会得到真正的满足。
You really feel almost like you're protecting yourself, because if this person knew what I was really like and what my real desires were, they would be running like hell.
你真的感觉像是在保护自己，因为如果这个人知道我真实的样子和真实的欲望，他们早就跑得远远的了。
When you look at the histories of these people, very often they come from childhoods where they were traumatized from situations where you would expect a young child to develop a sense that they didn't matter, that there was something wrong with them. And some compulsive lying may reflect attempts to rewrite history. If I can get this person to believe that I do have wealthy relatives and that I was pampered as a child and so on, maybe I can get myself to believe it too.
当你审视这些人的成长背景时，他们往往来自充满创伤的童年，在那些你会期待一个幼童感到自己无足轻重、觉得自己有问题的环境中长大。一些强迫性撒谎可能反映了他们试图重写历史的企图。如果我能让这个人相信我有有钱的亲戚，而且我小时候受过百般宠爱等等，也许我也能让自己相信这一点。
Take this story. Most of it unfolds in one of those dorm rooms that's claustrophobically dinky, 10 feet by 12 feet, only enough space for two identical single beds, two identical desks, two identical dressers, one narrow window which doesn't open very far. It's the kind of room where interior decorating means a poster-sized blow-up of a New Yorker cartoon. And the walls, they came that way-- green, lime green. And in this room at a small college in Nebraska live two guys who are just getting used to a new social hierarchy. They're in a world where it's possible to live with someone you're not that close to.
听听这个故事。故事大部分发生在一间典型的宿舍里，空间压抑狭小，大概10英尺乘12英尺，只能勉强放下两张一模一样的单人床、两张桌子、两个梳妆台，还有一扇打不开多宽的窄窗。这就是那种室内装饰仅限于一张《纽约客》漫画海报的房间。墙壁漆成了那种颜色——绿色的，青柠绿。在这个位于内布拉斯加州某小型学院的房间里，住着两个刚刚开始适应新社交等级制度的年轻人。他们身处的世界里，与一个并不那么亲近的人同住是常态。
I never considered him my friend, really. He was my roommate. He'd grown up in this little, tiny, tiny town in Nebraska. As it will become clear later, he had lied to me in telling me that he didn't actually grow up there. He'd grown up off in Boston, exotic, distant Boston.
我其实从没把他当朋友。他只是我的室友。他在内布拉斯加州一个极小极小的镇子上长大。后来事实证明，他对我撒了谎，他说他实际上不是在那里长大的。他说他是在波士顿长大的，那是异国情调的、遥远的波士顿。
It was when he started talking about Boston that things really started getting strange. And the story was something like this, that his father was an executive for a company that made satellites. He never told me the name of the company. It was an important international corporation in Boston. And they lived in Boston, just down the street from the Kennedy estate. And as a child, he used to play with the Kennedy children. He told me that the first time he met them, it was by sneaking into the Kennedy estate through the hedge. He snuck in and found the kids in the backyard and got to know them. I don't really remember the names, but he knew all the names. And he would describe their personalities to me. His best friend in the group was one of Robert Kennedy's sons.
事情是从他开始谈论波士顿之后变得奇怪的。他的故事大概是这样的：他父亲是一家制造卫星的公司的执行官。他从没告诉过我公司名字。那是一家位于波士顿的重要的国际化大公司。他们住在波士顿，离肯尼迪家族庄园只有几条街远。小时候，他经常和肯尼迪家的孩子一起玩。他告诉我，他第一次见到他们是通过树篱溜进肯尼迪庄园的。他溜了进去，发现孩子们在后院，然后就认识了他们。我不太记得具体名字了，但他知道所有人的名字。他还会向我描述他们的个性。他在那群人里最好的朋友是罗伯特·肯尼迪的儿子之一。
Eventually, about the time he was in high school, his father found out that he had a serious heart condition, and he couldn't work anymore. He had to quit. And not only did he have to quit, but he had to get away from this fast lane, high society lifestyle. So his father had decided to move the family back to the small town in Nebraska where he had grown up. So that was how he explained why he was in this small town, because on weekends, he would often go home to this small town to visit his parents.
最终，在他高中时期，他父亲发现自己患有严重的心脏病，不能再工作了。他不得不辞职。不仅辞职了，还不得不远离那种快节奏的高层生活方式。所以他父亲决定搬回他长大的内布拉斯加州小镇。这就是他解释自己为什么会在那个小镇的原因，因为周末他经常会回那个小镇去看望父母。
He often used to tell me that he would go to Boston on weekends in his father's private plane. He told me that he was being supported by the Kennedys, that the Kennedys were paying for him to go to college. And I asked him the first question that I think would occur to anybody at this moment-- Ted Kennedy was the one who was paying for him to go to college. I said, if Ted Kennedy is paying for you to go to school, why are you in Nebraska? Why aren't you going to Harvard or Yale or someplace? And he said, well, I have to stay close to my father, because my father is so ill. That made sense. Although I could have said something like, well, couldn't your dad just send the private plane to get you at Yale or Harvard?
他常说他周末会坐他父亲的私人飞机去波士顿。他告诉我，他在接受肯尼迪家族的资助，是肯尼迪家族在支付他上大学的费用。我问了他当时每个人都会想到的第一个问题——是泰德·肯尼迪（Ted Kennedy）在资助你上大学。我说：如果泰德·肯尼迪在付你的学费，你为什么会在内布拉斯加州？为什么不去哈佛、耶鲁之类的地方？他说：哦，我必须待在离父亲近的地方，因为我父亲病得太重了。这听起来有道理。虽然我可以反驳说：你父亲难道不能派私人飞机去耶鲁或哈佛接你吗？
I basically believed it, or at least never really thought it was worth my while to doubt it. And it went on that way for about five months, until one Sunday night, he came back. He'd been away all weekend. And he was acting sort of funny, kind of sheepish, but yet grinning a lot, as if he had a secret. I could tell from his behavior that it was the kind of secret that he wanted me to ask him about.
我基本上相信了，或者至少觉得没必要去怀疑。这种情况持续了大约五个月，直到一个周日晚上，他回来了。他整个周末都不在。他表现得有点滑稽，有点羞涩，但又一直在偷笑，好像藏着什么秘密。从他的行为中我能看出，那是种他希望我问起的秘密。
So finally I said, what's going on? Why are you acting so funny? And he sort of grinned and laughed a little. He said, I did something really silly this weekend. I said, oh, what did you do? I felt like I was playing along. I really, by this point, had serious doubts about anything he said. And he said, I swiped my father's plane. I said, oh, really? You just took it, huh? He said, yeah, I took it, and I just went for a ride. And I said, really? Where did you go? He said, I went to Boston. I said, why did you have to go to Boston without your dad knowing about it since you go there all the time? He said, well, it was a surprise because it was Rose's 92nd birthday party, and I really wanted to go. And my father didn't want me to go.
所以我终于问：怎么了？你为什么表现得这么滑稽？他笑了笑，笑得有点腼腆。他说：这个周末我做了件傻事。我说：噢，你做了什么？我觉得自己像在陪他演戏。到这时，对他说的任何话，我其实都已经产生了严重的怀疑。他说：我偷开了我父亲的飞机。我说：噢，真的吗？你就直接开走了，是吧？他说：是啊，我开走了，就是去兜了一圈。我说：真的吗？你去哪儿了？他说：我去了波士顿。我说：既然你经常去，为什么这次得背着你父亲去？他说：因为那是惊喜，是罗斯（Rose）的92岁生日派对，我真的很想去。而我父亲不想让我去。
And then it was a few weeks after that that I ran into, one day on campus, a woman who was a mutual friend of ours. There wasn't a romance between them, but she sort of wanted there to be one. And she said, well, I went home last weekend to the small town that she was from. And in the public library, she just happened to come across city directories for every small town in Nebraska. In these city directories for these small towns, they list who you are, where you live, what your occupation is, all the information you'd want to know about this small town. And so she pulled down the city directory off the shelf from the town that he was from and looked up his name and his family's name. And it said that his father was an electrician's assistant, not a retired executive, not someone who worked for this big satellite company, but an electrician's assistant. And at that moment, the lie seemed very sad.
那件事几周后，我在校园里偶然遇到了一个我们的共同朋友。他们之间没有恋情，但她曾有点想和他发展恋情。她说：我上周末回了一趟她老家的小镇。在公共图书馆里，她正好翻到了内布拉斯加州每个小镇的城市名录。在这些城市名录里，列出了镇上居民的姓名、住址、职业，以及你想知道的所有关于这个小镇的信息。于是她从架子上取下那个小镇的名录，查找了他的名字和他家人的名字。上面写着他父亲是一名电工助理，不是什么退休执行官，也不是什么在大卫星公司工作的人，只是个电工助理。在那一刻，那个谎言显得非常可悲。
I sort of felt like if I had confronted him, something terrible would have happened. He really just would have exploded, that he would have broke down, because someone would have kicked a big hole in this wall that he was trying to erect between himself and the truth.
我当时觉得，如果我拆穿了他，一定会发生什么可怕的事。他真的会崩溃的，因为有人会在他试图在自己和现实之间竖起的墙上，凿开一个大洞。
I was kind of scared, to tell you the truth, because once you learn that someone is capable of just completely deceiving you about who they are, where they're from, what their family is like, then you never know what's going to happen, because I found this out sometime before the end of the school year, so I had to live with this man. I had to sleep with this man in a small university dormitory room where my narrow single bed was about three feet away from his narrow single bed. And here was a man who would look at me with his eyes just glowing, with this very earnest, sort of frantically earnest look in his eyes, telling me about his father's job and how important it had been. I think he believed it. I think he really thought that he had done these things.
说实话，我当时有点害怕，因为一旦你知道某人有能力就“自己是谁、来自哪里、家庭背景”这类事情进行彻底的欺骗，你就永远不知道接下来会发生什么。我是在学年末之前发现这件事的，所以我不得不继续和这个男人住在一起。我得和这个男人睡在一间狭小的大学宿舍里，我的窄单人床离他的只有三英尺远。而就在这里，这个男人用那双闪闪发光的眼睛看着我，眼神里有一种极其真诚、几乎是狂热的认真，跟我讲着他父亲的工作以及这有多重要。我想他是信了。我想他真的觉得他经历过这些。
You have to consider the fact that he was an only child. And have you ever been to a really small town? If you've ever been to a really small town and you're a different kind of kid-- it doesn't really matter in what way you're different. But there's a good possibility that while you're growing up, you might look around you and not see anybody your own age with whom you feel you have anything in common. He might have grown up feeling really lonely. And so how did he respond? He created this fantasy where he wasn't just friends with one kid, he made it sound like-- he would talk about going swimming in their pool where there would be a dozen of them running around.
你必须考虑到他是个独生子。你去过那种极小的小镇吗？如果你去过那种极小的小镇，而且你是一个不同寻常的孩子——你以什么方式不同并不重要。但你很有可能在成长过程中，环顾四周，却发现找不到任何和你同龄、有共同语言的人。他可能是在极度孤独中长大的。那么他是如何回应的呢？他创造了这个幻想，在那里面，他不只是和一个孩子交朋友，他把它说成是……他会谈论去他们的泳池游泳，有十几个孩子在周围跑来跑去。
You can imagine them playing soccer on the lawn together. And there was this whole little community. You could definitely see the desire behind it. I guess I could see it because-- although the town that I was from was nowhere near as small as the town that he was from-- I grew up in an environment where I looked around me as a kid and just never really felt like there was anybody with whom I had much in common.
你能想象他们在草坪上一起踢足球。那个小世界里充满了生机。你绝对能看出这背后的渴望。我想我能看出来，因为——虽然我长大的地方远没有他那里那么小——但我成长的环境中，小时候环顾四周，确实从来没觉得有谁和我有共同语言。
At that time, I had never been to Boston either. And I went through a real Kennedy phase like a lot of kids do. I had a picture of John F. Kennedy on my wall, and the first biography that I ever read was a biography of John F. Kennedy. I even read Profiles in Courage.
那时候，我也从没去过波士顿。我和许多孩子一样，经历过一段真正的“肯尼迪狂热期”。我的墙上挂着约翰·F·肯尼迪的照片，我读过的第一本传记就是关于他的。我甚至读过《勇气档案》（Profiles in Courage）。
I'm asking each of you to be pioneers towards that new frontier. My call is to the young in heart--
我请求你们每个人成为通向新边疆的先驱。我的号召是给那些年轻的心灵——
If you're trying to embroider a life, a life in America, what myth are you going to try to hook yourself onto? Who are you going to pick on? It seems to me like the Kennedys might be most people's first choice of a myth. If I were going to pick one, that's probably the one I would pick too. In a way, maybe that's why I was so responsive to this.
如果你试图装饰一段生活，一段在美国的生活，你会选择勾连上哪种神话？你会选谁？在我看来，肯尼迪家族可能是大多数人神话的首选。如果我要选一个，那可能也是我会选的。从某种意义上说，也许这就是为什么我对他那么有共鸣。
I could picture him at the wheel of his father's plane. I sort of had this picture in my head of him driving the plane. And when you think about flying from Nebraska to Boston, that's like a three-hour flight, I think. And you just sort of imagine him going over Iowa and Illinois and Ohio and Indiana. And I just sort of saw him in my head doing this. And then, maybe the Kennedys have their own airstrip or something. Did he go to Logan International Airport right in the middle of downtown Boston? If he landed at Logan International Airport, did he just park the plane there, and did Ted have a limo waiting for him? I thought about all these things. I just kind of played with the idea myself. So in a way, I guess I was having some fun with the whole thing too.
我能想象他坐在他父亲飞机的驾驶舱里。我脑海里有他驾驶飞机的画面。如果你想从内布拉斯加州飞往波士顿，那大概是一趟三小时的飞行。你就能想象他飞过爱荷华州、伊利诺伊州、俄亥俄州和印第安纳州。我脑子里就浮现出他做这些事的画面。然后，也许肯尼迪家族有自己的私人机场之类的？他是降落在波士顿市中心的洛根国际机场吗？如果他降落在洛根国际机场，他是把飞机停在那里吗？泰德会开着加长豪华轿车在那里等他吗？我思考过所有这些事情。我自己也在玩这个幻想游戏。所以从某种程度上说，我想我也在跟着享受其中的乐趣。
You're listening to a special edition of This American Life, ah hour of true stories about compulsive liars.
你正在收听的是《美国生活》的特别节目，这是一个关于强迫性说谎者真实故事的专场。
I hope that every American, regardless of where he lives, will stop and examine his conscience about this and other related incidents.
我希望每一位美国人，无论他住在哪里，都能停下来检查自己的良心，关于这一事件及其他相关事件。
More lies in a minute when our program continues.
稍后节目继续，会有更多关于谎言的内容。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Most weeks, of course, on this program, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers and performers to tackle that theme. This week, however, as April Fools' Day approaches, we are taking a break from all that to bring you this hour-long special on liars, compulsive liars. Margy Rochlin narrates.
这是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，在大多数周里，我们节目会选择一个主题，邀请不同的作家和表演者来探讨。然而本周，随着愚人节的临近，我们暂停了惯例，为您带来这期关于骗子、强迫性说谎者的特别节目。玛吉·罗克林担任旁白。
The fact is, people want to believe in lies. People want to believe compulsive liars.
事实是，人们想要相信谎言。人们想要相信强迫性说谎者。
The lies they tell are usually appealing. And most lies told by anyone, most of them succeed because the person being lied to in some sense wants to believe in the lie. It's like you want to believe the magician. You don't want to believe it's a trick.
他们撒的谎通常很诱人。大多数人撒的谎都能成功，因为被骗的人在某种意义上想相信这个谎言。这就像你想相信魔术师一样。你不想相信那是骗局。
And you could keep believing the lie forever, except for this fact. A compulsive liar is compulsive. They can't leave well enough alone. They keep adding to the lie.
你本可以永远相信这个谎言，除了一个事实：强迫性说谎者是“强迫性”的。他们无法见好就收。他们不断地添油加醋。
Pushing things to the edge. Maybe that's why you do it as a liar. Maybe it loses its punch when you've repeated the same story over and over again, and it's universally accepted. Maybe you have to embellish it a little bit so that it is interesting. Probably what's more likely the case is that, when your lie is believed and it doesn't solve your internal pain, that you have to crank it up a notch so that maybe this time, I'll feel better. Maybe this time I'll be acceptable to myself. And maybe that's what pushes people ever closer to the brink and ultimately to the point where their lies are preposterous.
把事情推向极致。也许这就是身为骗子的你必须做的事。也许当你反复讲述同一个故事，且被普遍接受时，它就失去了冲击力。也许你必须稍微润色一下，让它变得更有趣。更有可能的情况是，当你的谎言被相信了，却无法解决你内心的痛苦时，你必须把它加码，也许这一次，我会感觉好一点。也许这一次，我能接受我自己。也许这就是把人们推向悬崖边缘的原因，并最终达到谎言极其荒谬的地步。
There's this thing that happens when you're involved with a compulsive liar. You go through this phase where you don't believe the things you're hearing, but you don't exactly disbelieve them either. You're in limbo. You think this person's nice, and the lies they're telling are so big that to think that they're lying would mean acknowledging that they're kind of crazy. So instead, you don't think anything.
当你与一个强迫性说谎者纠缠时，会发生一种情况。你会经历一个阶段：你不相信听到的事情，但又不完全不信。你处于一种悬浮状态。你觉得这个人很好，而他们撒的谎太大了，以至于如果认为他们在撒谎，就等于承认他们有点疯狂。所以，你什么都不想。
It's like this response that some animals have to danger called tonic immobility. When they're threatened and they can't get away, they just play dead. Their instincts tell them to stay motionless, and the problem is, once they've put themselves to sleep, it's hard to wake up.
这就像某些动物面对危险时的反应，叫“紧张性不动”（tonic immobility）。当受到威胁无法逃脱时，它们就会装死。它们的本能告诉它们保持静止，而问题是，一旦它们让自己陷入那种停滞，就很难醒过来。
I loved my father dearly, and I didn't want to believe these things about him. So I would just try to put it in the back of my mind and not think about it.
我深爱着我的父亲，我不想相信关于他的那些事。所以我试着把它们藏在脑海深处，不去想它。
This teenager, she stayed in that limbo phase for about a year. Her mother watched it happen.
这个十几岁的女孩，她在那种悬浮状态中待了大约一年。她的母亲看着这一切发生。
My daughter went along with this thinking that her father certainly wouldn't lie to her, though I had definitely told her that she had to be careful of this kind of thing.
我女儿一直跟着相信，认为她父亲肯定不会骗她，尽管我明确告诉过她，她必须警惕这类事情。
Here's what happened. She had a $1,400 college scholarship and sent the money to West Point, where she was enrolled. But she quit after basic training and switched to this other college in Virginia. Her parents were recently divorced and broke.
事情是这样的。她有一笔1400美元的大学奖学金，把钱寄给了她录取的西点军校。但她在基础训练后退学了，转到了弗吉尼亚州的另一所大学。她父母最近离婚了，身无分文。
She was depending on the return of this deposit at West Point. It never came, never came.
她指望着退还西点军校的那笔押金。但钱一直没到，一直没到。
I didn't know exactly when the check was coming. I didn't know when they were sending it, because my dad was receiving all my mail.
我不知道支票到底什么时候到。我不知道他们什么时候寄出来的，因为我父亲接收了我所有的信件。
He kept telling her that the check hadn't come.
他一直告诉她支票还没到。
My dad just kept telling me different stories.
我父亲一直编造不同的故事告诉我。
For months.
持续了数月。
When he would tell me reasons why the check wasn't coming to me, I had trouble believing it, but I let it slide. I thought he loved me so much that he wouldn't do anything like this to me. And I just didn't want to not believe him. But I probably should have.
当他跟我解释支票为什么还没寄到时，我很难相信，但我选择了姑息。我以为他深爱着我，绝不会对我做这种事。我只是不想去怀疑他，但也许我本该怀疑的。
He told me that it was sent to my old address where my mom lived before she moved, and it had to be sent back to West Point to have a new check made. And then it was delayed up at West Point for some reason.
他告诉我，支票寄到了我妈搬家前居住的旧地址，必须退回到西点军校重新开具。然后因为某种原因，支票在西点军校那边耽搁了。
He told her that he had had various calls with West Point and that they had said they were deducting certain amounts for uniforms. The check never came.
他告诉她，他和西点军校通了多次电话，对方说要扣除一部分制服费用。支票始终没有寄到。
Then another time happened where he said it was lost in the mail, and it never got there. And I didn't know what to believe. I was like, well, what do I say? But I didn't really think hard about it and think, oh, my dad's not truthful and he's this and that. At that time, I didn't think about that. I just didn't want to.
还有一次他说支票在邮寄过程中丢了，始终没到账。我不知道该相信什么。我就想，我该说什么呢？但我并没有深想，也没有觉得“我爸在撒谎”、“他这人怎么样”。当时我根本没往那方面想，我只是不想去想。
My mom told me stories about what my father had done to her.
我妈跟我讲过我父亲对她做过的事。
I lived with this man for 19 years, and I knew that he lied. If he told me the sun was shining, I would have to look before I believed him. It got to that point.
我和这个男人生活了19年，我知道他撒谎。就算他说太阳出来了，我也得亲眼看看才敢相信。已经到了这种地步。
When my mom told me the situation about what my father had done, I had trouble believing what she was saying. I would agree with her, but deep inside, I didn't know exactly how to feel, because I was split in between them a lot after the separation occurred. I was the person in the middle. And I had to go in between the two. And I didn't know what to believe of what I was hearing. And I just tried to blow off anything I heard so that it just wouldn't affect me.
当我妈告诉我关于我父亲做的那件事时，我很难相信她的话。我表面上附和她，但内心深处，我不知道该有什么样的感觉，因为在他们分居后，我经常处于两难的境地。我夹在中间，必须在他们两人之间周旋。我不知道该相信谁说的。我只能试着不去理会我听到的一切，这样就不会影响到我。
Finally, he said, a check has come, and I have taken it to my attorney's office for safekeeping because there are thefts in our neighborhood, and I don't want someone to steal this check.
最后，他说支票寄到了，他已经把支票放在律师办公室保管，因为我们社区有失窃案，他不希望支票被偷。
So he had it locked up in the lawyer's safe. And I thought, I guess that's understandable. However, it's kind of stupid. But I didn't want to not believe him with it.
所以他把它锁在律师的保险箱里。我想，这倒是可以理解。虽然有点傻，但我不想去怀疑他。
Then he told me that the lawyer had to be called back into the military because of the Operation Desert Storm. They had to go back into the reserves. And he said that he was the only one who could open the safe. And I thought that was pretty stupid too, because what if he died? Who would be able to get into the safe then? There had to be someone who could open the safe. Either his partner or his secretary or someone could get into the safe.
后来他告诉我，因为“沙漠风暴”行动，那位律师被征召回部队了。他们必须重回预备役。他说他是唯一能打开保险箱的人。我觉得这也很扯，万一他死了怎么办？那谁还能打开保险箱？肯定还有别人能打开，要么是他的合伙人，要么是他的秘书之类的。
So I finally got too suspicious and thought it was a very stupid thing he was saying to me.
所以我终于开始怀疑了，觉得他跟我说的话非常荒谬。
And then finally I said, look, you really need to call the attorney's office.
最后我说，听着，你真的需要给律师事务所打个电话。
And I called the lawyer's office and found out that the man didn't even know about it. And he was actually at home, had not been sent away. And when he got on the phone, I was just like, what? I could not believe it. I was in shock. I mean, I almost had trouble talking to him, because I didn't expect him to be there in the first place. And I had asked him about the check. And he said he had never heard anything about it, and he hadn't seen my dad in a long time. It was just like a load just was put on my shoulders. And I just could not believe it. My whole body just went limp.
我给律师事务所打了电话，发现那个人根本不知道这件事。他其实就在家里，根本没被派走。当他接电话时，我简直惊呆了，不敢相信。我当时震惊了。甚至连话都说不出来，因为我根本没想到他会在那儿。我问了他关于支票的事，他说他从未听说过，而且很久没见我爸了。那一刻，我感觉肩上的重担卸下了，但我还是不敢相信。我整个人都瘫软了。
So that evening, I called my dad. And I was crying on the phone. And I asked him what he had done with it. And he said that he had lost the check in the mail. And I just didn't believe him. Finally, I just got to the point where I just wasn't believing what he was saying.
那天晚上，我给我爸打了电话。我在电话里哭着问他到底把支票怎么了。他说支票在邮寄中丢了。我根本不信。最后我真的到了那种地步，我对他说的任何话都不再相信了。
She called me, and she said, you were right. And she's crying on the phone. It's just horrible.
她打电话给我说：“你是对的。”她在电话里哭着。这真是太可怕了。
I don't have to deal with him anymore. And that's what my younger daughter said. "This is worse for us than it even was for you, Mom, because you got away. And he will always be my father." And a man or anyone who lies like this is not in control. I don't think that he's in control. And that's the hardest part for me. I can't protect them.
我再也不用和他打交道了。我小女儿也是这么说的。“妈，这对我们来说比对你更糟，因为你已经逃出来了。但他永远是我父亲。”一个这样撒谎的男人，或者任何这样撒谎的人，都已经失去了自控。我不认为他还能控制自己。这是最让我难受的部分。我无法保护他们。
I was Daddy's little girl, and everybody knew it. And I loved him more than anything in the whole world. Every once in a while I think that this could not have happened and that it can't be real. And I don't want to think about it and admit that it happened. And sometimes I try to put my mind on other things and try not to think about it, but it's always there. And it is always digging at me. It just hurts. It hurts in your heart. I feel like a part of my heart was taken out when he did this to me. It's really hard to explain, but it just feels like part of me is missing now that I don't trust my father anymore.
我曾是爸爸的乖女儿，大家都知道。我爱他胜过世上的一切。偶尔我会觉得这不可能发生，这不是真的。我不想去想，也不想承认这件事发生了。有时我试着把心思放在别处，不去想它，但它一直都在那里。它总是在啃噬着我。这真的让人心痛。心都碎了。我感觉他对我做这些事时，我的一部分心被掏空了。这很难解释，但现在我不信任父亲了，感觉自己像是缺失了一块。
I'll never know why he did it. I don't think he'll ever admit it to me why.
我永远不会知道他为什么要这么做。我觉得他永远不会向我坦白原因。
She was Daddy's girl. She is no longer.
她曾是爸爸的乖女儿。但现在不是了。
When the big lie comes down, it makes you question the fabric of all of your experiences. You don't believe anybody. You don't believe anything. And the lies act like a weird kind of antimatter on all of your memories. You don't know what to think about the past. It shakes up your view of the world as a safe place.
当弥天大谎被戳穿时，你会质疑你所有经历的基础。你不相信任何人。你不相信任何事。这些谎言就像一种奇怪的反物质，侵蚀着你所有的记忆。你不知道该如何看待过去。这动摇了你对世界是一个安全之所的认知。
So to restore some kind of order, you launch this private investigation. You make telephone calls. You look for clues in old letters. Then you combine the evidence with your own memories and start sorting everything into two different piles. There's a pile of real things and a pile of things that were totally invented. You think that if you can make this classification system work, then you can just throw out the pile of fake stuff, reconstruct reality, and go on with your life.
为了恢复某种秩序，你开启了一项私人调查。你打电话，在旧信件里寻找线索。然后，你将证据与你自己的记忆结合起来，开始把一切分成两堆：一堆是真的，一堆是彻底编造的。你以为只要能理清这套分类系统，就能扔掉那堆假货，重建现实，然后继续生活。
The problem is, it can't be done. There's all these tiny pieces of data which don't make sense but are too important to discard. So as a matter of convenience, you start this third pile and you call it "don't know." So now there's "true," "false," and "don't know." And unfortunately, the "don't know" pile, it's where almost everything ends up.
问题是，这根本做不到。有太多零碎的信息虽然不合逻辑，却又重要到无法丢弃。所以为了方便起见，你开始整理第三堆，把它称为“不知道”。现在有了“真”、“假”和“不知道”。不幸的是，“不知道”的那一堆，几乎装下了所有东西。
The best thing that could happen to me, the thing that would allow me to go to my grave probably more stabilized would be if he said, no, this is what the truth is really. This is what was true, and this is what wasn't.
如果他能说“不，这才是真相”，说清楚哪些是真的，哪些是假的，这对我来说是最好的解脱，也能让我更平静地走进坟墓。
Sometimes you can spend years sorting out the truth. This woman runs a dance company. She had a fiance. He seemed to have a lot of money. They lived in an expensive apartment, and he bought her a car. They were together for three years.
有时你可能花上几年时间去梳理真相。这位女士经营着一家舞蹈公司。她有个未婚夫，看起来很有钱。他们住着昂贵的公寓，他还给她买了辆车。他们在一起三年了。
Then weird things started happening. Citicorp Bank called me to say when I was going to make a payment. And I said, you've got to be out of your minds. I hate you guys. You have investments in South Africa. You screwed over a bank account of mine a long time ago. I wouldn't have a Citicorp-- "Well, you have three Citicorp accounts." And they're, like, $10,000 overdue.
然后奇怪的事情开始发生了。花旗银行打电话问我什么时候还款。我说，你们疯了吧？我讨厌你们。你们在南非有投资，很久以前还坑过我的账户。我才不会办花旗……“好吧，但你有三个花旗账户。”而且都已经逾期一万多美元了。
So I call him up, and he's like, I can explain it. I'm like, good. He's like, send me the information. He has this way of talking to me that will calm me down and make it seem like everything you ever wanted could come true. And he also had this demeanor that, I'll take care of everything. Don't worry. I'll take care of everything. And I would believe that he would take care of it.
于是我给他打电话，他说：“我能解释。”我说：“好啊。”他说：“把资料发给我。”他总有那种方式让我冷静下来，让我觉得一切想要的都能成真。他还有一种“一切有我，别担心，我会搞定一切”的风度。我当时就信了他会处理好。
I figured out later how he did all of this stuff and how easy it is for anyone to do. Once a week, you get something in the mail that says, you have been preapproved for a gold card or whatever. Most people just pitch those in the garbage. Well, he didn't. He filled them all out. And since we'd filled out one credit card together, he knew all my information. Your next-door neighbor could be doing it to you right now, and you don't know.
后来我才发现他是怎么做这些事的，而且这事儿对谁来说都太容易了。你每周都会收到邮件，说你已预获金卡之类的申请资格。大多数人直接扔进垃圾桶。但他没有。他把它们全填了。因为我们一起办过一张信用卡，他知道我所有的个人信息。你隔壁的邻居现在可能就在对你做同样的事，而你根本不知道。
There were three Citibank cards. They were starting repossession on my car. There was $8,000 on that. There was a gold card that had a $5,000 credit limit, and it was run up beyond its credit limit. All told, I owed, like, $65,000 to $75,000. I was making $26,000 a year. And I found out about all of this all in, like, 48 hours, because I found out that he had been seeing someone else.
当时有三张花旗信用卡。他们开始收回我的车，上面还有8000美元的贷款。还有一张额度5000美元的金卡，透支额度已经爆了。总共加起来，我欠了大概6万5到7万5美元。而我一年的收入才2.6万美元。我是在48小时内发现这一切的，因为我发现他还在跟别人来往。
We had had this really tumultuous thing where he called me up in a total fried state, and I didn't know what was wrong. And I mean, he was an emotional basket case. It turns out he'd been dating someone in New York, and she dumped him. And he called me for sympathy. And he couldn't really tell me why he was so distraught. So I called him back. I asked him about it, and the whole story comes out, that he'd been seeing this other woman. He was madly in love with her. She had dumped him and had just gone to Australia to marry someone else. On the one hand, I'm being the good friend. "Well, how do you feel about this?" And then I'm like, "What are you, crazy?"
我们当时经历了一场极其混乱的事，他突然崩溃给我打电话，我不知道出了什么事。他当时情绪彻底失控了。原来他在纽约一直在跟别人约会，结果被甩了。他打电话给我寻求安慰。他没法告诉我他为什么这么心烦意乱。所以我回拨了电话，问他到底怎么回事，结果全说了出来，他一直在和另一个女人交往。他疯狂地爱着她，结果她甩了他，去澳大利亚嫁给别人了。一方面，我还在尽朋友的职责说：“你感觉如何？”然后我心想：“你疯了吗？”
I mean, I felt literally like someone had ripped my innards out, like my whole world was imploding, which is why I went to bed. Everything in the air was so heavy. It was too much work to get to the phone. It was too much work to put food in my mouth. It was too much work to get up, put my clothes on, and go to the office. And my friends said, you have to get better. Too many of us need you, which is always a good way to jump-start.
我感觉就像有人掏空了我的内脏，感觉整个世界都在崩塌，所以我躺倒在床上。空气里的一切都那么沉重。拿起电话太累了，往嘴里塞食物太累了，起床穿衣服去办公室也太累了。我的朋友说，你必须好起来。我们需要你的人太多了，这通常是重新振作的好方法。
Unfortunately, I'm one of these people who needs to be needed. And even though I hate that role that I've carved for myself, it's like-- you know, your cat needs you. My cat has saved me from potential suicide twice. Ariel needs to be fed. She needs someone to clean the litter box.
不幸的是，我就是那种需要被需要的人。尽管我讨厌自己扮演的这个角色，但就像……你知道，你的猫需要你。我的猫救过我两次，差点让我自杀。阿里尔需要被喂食。她需要有人清理猫砂盆。
It's so easy to be taken in. It's this fantasy that they create that you want to be in. I mean, part of it, I'm madly in love with this guy. And he said, you're an artist. You should be doing artwork. You shouldn't be dealing with your finances. I'll support you. I'll take over all the finances. And it was like God dropped out of the sky and said, "Here. You've worked hard. You deserve this. Here."
被人骗太容易了。那是他们编织的让你想深陷其中的幻想。我当时疯狂地爱着这个家伙。他说：“你是艺术家，你应该搞创作，不该去处理财务，我养你，我接管所有财务。”那感觉就像上帝从天而降说：“给你，你辛苦了，这是你应得的。”
Money has always been a really stressful thing for me. My family didn't have a lot of money. You have to understand my history. I was the oldest child. When my dad died, I was 13. My mother didn't know how to deal with it. I had three kids under me. I became the second adult in the family when I was 13 years old. I started drinking coffee. I started going to parent-teacher meetings. I was always mother to everyone else. And I was the head dancer in a company, and then I had my own company. And here was someone who came along and said, "I'll take some of that weight off. I'll take care of you." And I've been one of these people who always had to do that for everyone else. So your deepest, darkest, secret desire is that someone, somewhere will do that for you.
金钱对我来说一直是个很大的压力源。我家没多少钱。你得了解我的背景。我是长女，我爸去世时我才13岁。我妈不知道怎么处理，下面还有三个孩子。我在13岁时就成了家里的第二个大人。我开始喝咖啡，开始去开家长会，我一直扮演着所有人的母亲。后来我是舞团的首席舞者，然后自己开了公司。这时有个人出现说：“我会帮你分担些压力，我会照顾你。”我一直是个不得不去照顾别人的人，所以你内心深处最隐秘的愿望，就是有人能在某个地方为你做这些事。
The thing about him is, I think that he was probably really, really intuitive, because I think, perhaps, what he's able to do is become a mirror of your secret fantasy life, of your secret desires. And I don't know, because I'd like to be a fly on the wall and see if he does that with other people, whether the fantasies are always different, or whether he's so ingrained-- See, there's two things. Either he's this kind of person who's so intuitive that he can create a fantasy that mirrors whatever your fantasy life is, or he picks out people who will buy his fantasy life. And I don't know which one it is.
关于他，我觉得他可能真的非常有直觉，因为或许他能成为你秘密幻想生活、秘密愿望的镜像。我不知道，因为我真想当个隐形人看看他是否对别人也这样，看看那些幻想是否总是不同，还是他已经深入骨髓……看，有两种可能。要么他是那种非常有直觉的人，能创造出一个反映你任何幻想的幻境；要么他专门挑选那些会买他幻境账的人。我不知道是哪一种。
He had this entire fiction of his life. I believe some of it was fiction. I'm sure some of it was true, because I don't think he would have ended up the way that he ended up if some of the stories that he told were not true. When he told these stories, it was passionate. It was like the best theater you've ever attended. It was the best monologue.
他编造了关于他生活的整部虚构剧。我相信有些是虚构的。但我肯定有些是真的，因为如果他讲的故事里没有真事，我不觉得他最终会落到那个地步。当他讲这些故事时，非常动情。那简直是你见过最好的表演，最好的独白。
He was from Ireland. He was an earl or a lord. I can never figure out what those people are. His father had been very prominent in politics. He had been given a different last name. He had been given the last name of the ancestral family because his father had singled him out as being the chosen son or whatever. And then his father totally mistreated him and abused him emotionally. And the IRA blew up their home at some point. It was this tragic existence, this really compelling tale of a person kind of drifting through life, looking for something they could hang on to.
他说他来自爱尔兰，是伯爵还是公爵。我搞不清楚那些人的头衔。他父亲在政界很显赫。他被改了个姓，改成了祖上的姓，因为他父亲选定他作为继承人还是怎么的。后来他父亲又极度虐待他，对他进行情感霸凌。爱尔兰共和军在某个时候炸毁了他们的家。那是一个悲剧性的人生，一个在生活中漂泊、寻找依靠的非常引人入胜的故事。
He was a director. He directed commercials for one of the big advertising agencies. And then when his wife died, he made these brilliant commercials. And then he sold everything he owned. And he went down, and he became a mercenary fighter in border disputes down in South America. Maybe he did that. Maybe he didn't.
他说他是导演，给一家大广告公司导过商业广告。在他妻子去世后，他制作了这些精彩的广告。然后他卖掉了所有家当，去南美洲当了一名雇佣兵。也许他做过，也许没有。
The problem that I still have is I don't know which were lies. I don't know what's real and what's not. I mean, I've sat and thought, well, that couldn't be true. But I went to Ireland. I went to the place where his house supposedly would be. And there is a house that underwent significant damage. If I really cared to make a life project out of this, I could research every aspect of what he told me.
我依然面临的问题是，我不知道哪些是谎言。我不知道什么是真，什么是假。我曾坐下来想，这不可能是真的。但我去过爱尔兰，去了他所谓的房子所在地。那里确实有一座遭受过严重破坏的房子。如果我真的愿意把它当作人生的项目，我是可以去研究他所说的每一件事的。
Oh, he didn't completely disappear, though. He still will call me. I'll be cooking dinner at my house. My phone number's not listed. I've moved twice since he knew me. And he'll call. "How are you?" And I'll be like, "I'm fine."
哦，他并没有彻底消失。他还会打电话给我。我在家做晚饭的时候。我的电话号码是不公开的。从他认识我以后，我搬了两次家。但他还是会打来。“你好吗？”我说：“我挺好。”
People have said, do you think he really loved you? Or people have told me, he never really loved you. He just used you. My mother was key among that school of people. And this is part of what messes with my head still, because I don't believe that I could be so far off the mark. I mean, I believe that he truly loved me. When he looked into my eyes and he said, I love you, when he calls me back and says he-- there's no need for him, at this point-- if he really is trying to make this con go down, he wouldn't try to keep in contact with me. He keeps coming back. And I believe it's because he really did love me.
有人问我，你觉得他真的爱过你吗？或者有人跟我说，他从未真正爱过你，他只是在利用你。我妈就是这派人的领头人物。这依然让我感到困惑，因为我不相信我居然会错得这么离谱。我是说，我相信他真的爱过我。当他看着我的眼睛说“我爱你”的时候，当他回过头来找我的时候……如果他真的只是为了诈骗，他没必要现在还试图保持联系。他不断回来找我，我相信那是因为他真的爱过我。
I think for a while afterwards, I created a new fiction. This is a bad dream. And I'm going to wake up, and he's going to come back. And he will have gotten this fabulous job, and he's going to pay off all these debts. And I'm not going to have to deal with this. It didn't happen. But he kept saying, I swear to you, I will pay you back. I will make this up to you. I really think he believed it. I think he had no basis in reality in general. And I really wanted to believe him. I really wanted to believe that he wasn't this horrible ogre who had done this to me.
我想有一段时间，我编造了一个新的虚构故事。这是一个噩梦。我会醒来，他会回来。他会找到一份棒极了的工作，还清所有债务。我不用处理这些烂摊子。但这并没有发生。但他一直说，我向你发誓，我会还给你的。我会补偿你的。我真的觉得他自己都信了。我觉得他基本没有现实基础。我真的很想相信他。我真的很想相信他不是那个对我做出这种事的恐怖怪兽。
I don't know. Am I not vindictive? Sometimes I'd like to kill him. Mostly I'd just like to have the dream back. I really wish that there had been someone out there existing in the world who was who he said he was. That would be great.
我不知道。我难道不记仇吗？有时我真想杀了他。但更多时候，我只是希望能找回那个梦。我真心希望在这个世界上，曾经存在过那么一个人，他就是他说的那样。那该多好。
I think that he truly, truly loved me and probably didn't want things to turn out the way they did. But he was so deeply entrenched in that. He couldn't say, OK, erase everything I've ever said to you. This is the real story. This is who I really am. And he may very well have thought, this is going to be the one that I'm going to change. He talked about having children, long-range commitment kinds of things.
我觉得他是真心、真心地爱过我，大概也不想事情变成这样。但他陷得太深了。他没法说：“好吧，把你听过的都删掉。这是真实的故事，这才是真正的我。”他很可能觉得：“这次我会改的。”他谈论过要孩子，谈论过长期的承诺之类的事。
Because the house of cards didn't fall down for at least a year and a half. Bills were being paid. It was one of these catch-up games. So maybe he thought, I'm just going to get one more credit card and pay this off to keep it afloat, because I'm going to get this job. And I'm going to be making $80,000 a year, and we're not going to have to worry about anything. And just the next credit card. Oh, I've got to get one more. And I'll get one more, and I'll pay those off, just to keep it going, just keep it going. For the longest time, even after I said to him, look at what you've done, look at what you've done to me, he said, I will make it up to you. I will pay every cent back. I don't know.
因为这座纸牌屋至少撑了一年半没倒。账单一直在付。这是一种拆东墙补西墙的游戏。所以也许他想，我只要再办一张信用卡就能还上这个缺口，因为我快要找到工作了。我会年薪8万，我们什么都不用愁了。只要再办一张卡。哦，我还得再办一张。再办一张，我就会把它们都还清，只要让它运转下去，让它运转下去。很长一段时间，即使在我对他说“看看你做的好事，看看你把我害成什么样”之后，他还是说，我会补偿你的。我会把每一分钱都还上。我不知道。
Maybe he just sold me all that. Maybe he's the best actor in the whole world, Academy Award winner. And maybe he just creates this character, this tragic-- I don't know. It's like standing on air. It's like nothing is too far-fetched. Nothing is impossible. It's like a whole crisis of faith. What do you believe in? I don't know what I can believe in. Can you believe in things you see? Can you believe in things you hold? Can you believe in looking into someone? Can you believe when someone swears? Can you believe? What do you believe?
也许他只是在演给我看。也许他是世界上最好的演员，奥斯卡奖得主。也许他只是创造了这个悲剧角色……我不知道。那感觉就像站在半空中。感觉一切都那么不可思议。没什么是不可能的。就像是一场信仰危机。你相信什么？我不知道我还能相信什么。你能相信你看到的吗？你能相信你拿在手里的吗？你能相信看向某个人吗？你能相信某人的发誓吗？你能相信吗？你到底相信什么？
Once I interviewed a parapsychologist, and this is what he told me about ghosts. The peskiest ghosts, the kind that do the most haunting, are the ones who left this world so abruptly that they don't even know that they're dead. He said it's like if two people driving in a car get into this horrible car wreck where the driver is safe but the passenger is catapulted through the front windshield and dies. The parapsychologist said that the soul of the passenger can be ripped from their body so quickly that their energy remains. The specter, it's confused. Everything happened so suddenly. And that's why it keeps bothering those it left behind.
有一次我采访了一位超心理学家，他关于鬼魂是这样告诉我的。最麻烦的鬼魂，那种作祟最严重的，往往是死得太突然，甚至不知道自己已经死了。他说这就像两辆车里的人遭遇了可怕的车祸，驾驶员平安无事，乘客却被弹出了挡风玻璃死亡。超心理学家说，乘客的灵魂会被撕裂得太快，以至于他们的能量留存了下来。幽灵感到困惑。一切发生得太突然了。这就是为什么它总是去骚扰那些被留下的人。
Once you discover that everything someone has been telling you about themselves is basically nonsense, it's like you suddenly find yourself alone in that car. The person who was sitting next to you no longer exists. All that's left is this vapory memory. And figuring out what to think about the experience ends up taking people years. You're stuck for a while between several contradictory feelings about the liar-- pity, anger, sympathy. You don't know what think. You wait until you just don't care about it anymore. And the people I talked to, they say they view the world differently now.
一旦你发现别人告诉你的一切关于他们自己的事基本上都是废话，你就好像突然发现自己独自坐在那辆车里。坐在你身边的那个人已经不存在了。剩下的只是一段虚无缥缈的记忆。而理清对这段经历的看法，往往需要人们花费数年时间。你会有一段时间陷入对那个撒谎者几种矛盾的情绪中：同情、愤怒、怜悯。你不知道该想什么。你只能等着，直到你不再在乎为止。我采访过的人说，他们现在看世界的眼光不同了。
Now I don't trust anyone. My husband says, you are the most suspicious woman I've ever encountered. It's like, I go through his mail.
现在我不信任任何人。我丈夫说，你是我见过最疑神疑鬼的女人。他指我甚至会去翻他的信件。
Ever since then, every time I meet someone who strikes me as dishonest, there's this moment of real fear when I wonder, what could they do to me?
从那以后，每次我遇到让我觉得不诚实的人，总会产生一种真实的恐惧，我在想：他们会对我做什么？
See, it's one of the reasons why I live in this apartment alone, because I would never, ever move in with someone I didn't know. And even people that you do know, they don't turn out to be what you thought they were.
瞧，这就是为什么我一个人住在这个公寓的原因，因为我永远不会和我不了解的人同居。即使是你了解的人，最后也可能和你想象的不一样。
Our program on compulsive liars was produced by Margy Rochlin and myself, narrated by Margy Rochlin. Post-production by Peter Clowney. If you'd like a copy of this program, call us at WBEZ in Chicago, 312-832-3380.
我们的这期关于强迫性撒谎者的节目由玛吉·罗克林和我制作，玛吉·罗克林担任旁白。后期制作彼得·克洛尼。如果您想要节目副本，请致电芝加哥WBEZ电台，电话312-832-3380。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带来《美国生活》的更多故事。